[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue aux touches
comme on est avec nous ce soir
françois wyss ouais salut françois sera
un pêcheur isabelle morini bosc était
avec nous on aura black et morales voile
à taux plein de faire quoi que tu fais
exactement je répète ma chronique un
voyage connaît très très bien ta
chronique c'est pas du tout accroché
tu es en train d'essayer de répéter
faire une maquette au cas où tu
remplaces cyril on n'a jamais décider
qui remplaçait syrie tu arrêtes de me
pointer du doigt s'il te plaît se pointe
pas du doigt je suis en train de charme
est un serpent tu connais pas eu tous
mes facultés
j'ai grandi en inde avec dix bonnes et
si chère à thierry petit côté alors à
plélan c'est leur truc des noms des
questions cafetière de jolies courbes
ont attaqué une excellente nouvelle à
t'annoncer j'ai trouvé les clés de mon
coeur 30 c'est déjà j'en ai même fait un
double au côté les perdre et j'ai trouvé
les clés la loge de cyril c'est la
première fois qu'on a accès à sa loge on
va pas se priver soit pourquoi tu
marches comme ça parce qu'on l'accepté
ans seuls quatre heures s'est plus
imposé des raisons de budget à bavois la
norme est en tête
t'as pas peur qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient devant cyril et 18h38 l'émission
allez dans dix minutes
il n'est jamais arrivé aussitôt de sa
vie ça n'arrivera pas trop inquiète pas
tu peux y aller dix minutes avant
arrière et
j'ai fait un jeu vous savez ce que vous
faites est non mais celui de pete alors
il fait guerman jeudi c'est mieux ne
rien en moi et je n'ai mis tout ça il ya
même des nougats ils sont l'avenir les
glaces à la wii
son côté li mars et nous donne un son de
montélimar je n'ai pas vérifié en fait
j'ai battu je vais faire tout ce
qu'elles sont demandées mal nous garde
et ta connerie tu verrais ferrasse avait
pas de combrée connard
borg a mis en scène et derrière je sais
que cette tenue là c'est dégueulasse non
matin cravate le costard ils sont où là
on n'est pas dans les années collège
attend excuse moi de voyager un tout
petit peu mais house of craft
washington washington états unis etats
unis look détente friday wear
excuse moi de sortir un peu loin oui
mais on est jeudi dacquois away pride et
c'est vendredi
excuse moi mais c'est en fait j'ai fait
la fan sur scène si tu es tu avec série
puis chute en 2e année trois à deux pas
de pas de bile between sa vie à rentrer
ouais bon tu fermes ta gueule mais j'ai
dû nouveau à l'est du nouveau la liste
des personnes qui s'attaque à cyril dans
les médias et à ce jour aussi longue que
la pub pendant touche pas à mon poste
look at that alors peut-être si je
voudrais juste dire ça à s'aimer comme
il aime bien répondre à la nouvelle star
c'est pas l'animateur qui est une star
les voilà marines james fait son entrée
dans la liste des ennemis de cyril un
soutien plus à l'est alors j'ai tout ça
te fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors tu vas fermer ta gueule chamond
notre calme tu vois la place de qui un
moment donné d'un loup garou de niche où
poser les bonnes questions
tu dois mettre le doigt sur quelque
chose qui se décrit cette merde
kameni devinette quelle est la
différence entre ce surligneurs et cyril
hahn main au choix le stabilo boss
hockey autre annonce mardi
alors j'espère au moins que tu as des
nouveautés pour qu'on prenne la place de
cyril qu'est ce qu'il ya de nouveau
puisque tu fais des blagues de mer nada
walou que tu chies 0 personne n'a parlé
contre lui dans les médias
l'enquète est au point mort je sais pas
comment on va se sortir de ce marasme
d'ailleurs si tu commence et il s'est
débrouillé pour arriver à prendre le
contrôle des médias comme ça et
présenter une émission qui marche aussi
bien que la nôtre du jeu c'est assez
simple comme tout professionnel des
médias c'est un vrai travail d'acharnés
quoi c'est le goût de la chose bien
faite
y aller à fond le sens de la répartie
puis du boulot du boulot et du boulot
non mais sérieusement
non sérieusement il montrer son cul sur
communal et proxy quoi ah non tu sais ce
qu'il te reste à faire quoi ok mais non
c'est mal me connaître je meurs j'ai une
famille des valeurs à défendre
jamais au grand jamais je ne montrerai
montcuq au réussir à la télé je te
laisse bercer lavanant la voirie la dîme
il a je fais pas de montrer mon cul puis
finalement on voit mon cul ça va à ces
jeux on voit arriver à une amère bio
mettre les matins vraiment je je je te
laisse 15 ans que je le connais première
fox agréablement surpris par la personne
mais avec amis parce que y'a rien de
plus triste vers le gag prévisible à la
craie et ça ce serait enregistrée jeudi
eh bien je regarde la house of crade
sait très bien faire c'est très
professionnel c'est très intéressant
[Musique]
camille web à london en externat tu m'as
piqué ma veste a pas 10 ou non je tend
les bras tant les bras tout de suite tu
m'as piqué ma veste ou c'est du sept ans
tu ne la rendra demain je mets ça sous
le tapis pendant 24 heures car j'ai une
grande nouvelle à t'annoncer engendré
fait au quai disponibles pour mariage
bar mitzvah baptêmes et communions et
enterrements de vie de jeune fille
la liste des soutiens de célina pour la
présidence de france télévisions
s'allonge de jour en jour on dirait le
nez de pinocchio et sa part de l'un
regarde ça je soutiens la candidature de
cyril hanouna à la présidence de france
télévisions doublé déry s'affale y
penser motus de 8h à 12h
alors si riche on y croit je soutiens
série la nomma à la présidence de france
télévisions bonjour à tous
alors si vous souhaitez voir du ping
pong 365 jours par an de 20h à minuit en
prime time sur france télévisions un
seul président pour cela cyril hanouna
je vote pour lui je soutient
officiellement la candidature de mme ans
cyril hanouna que j'adore je soutiens la
candidature de cyril hanouna au poste de
président de france télévisions cyril
j'ai toujours cru en toi je suis sûr que
tu peux apporter plein de choses à la
france alors on est de tout coeur avec
toi
votez cyril hanouna alesi un message
très important en tout cas voilà mois
karine ferri je soutiens cyril hanouna à
la présidence de france télévisions la
présidence de france télévisions cyril
hanouna
mais je tiens
fort fort très fort alors fort mais
c'est que des invités qu'on a eu depuis
quinze jours dans tes pelleteuse exact
c'est parce que j'ai pas encore tu vois
je suis pas encore complètement et oui
dans le milieu des médias
donc tu voi ampoules qui est éclairée au
dessus de ma tête a pas du tout à se
dire que le graphiste est déjà parti
chez lui bon très bien j'ai eu une idée
quoi qu'il en soit j'ai peut-être
quelqu'un qui pourrait lui sauver la
mise
nos remarques j'ai besoin de toi pour me
débarrasser du back in town dispo fin de
semaine bon soit vendredi tu fais moi ok
mais y'aura combal bomba d'accord bon
allez je fais un gros bisou gros poutou
camille j'ai dû nouveau qu'est ce que
c'est que ça nos propositions pour l'an
prochain
non lui proposait surtout pour l'an
prochain sont là ça c'est le top 100
mais qu'adopter classement adopteunmec
des hommes les plus sexy du paf énorme
qui s'est le premier largarde l'homme le
plus beau le plus sexy de l'année est
sur d8
il s'agit de bertrand chamorro ch tu
fous ben je me la pète je suis quand
même numéro un sur le classement adopte
un mec ça c'est rien ça c'est bon aussi
je suis dans classement c'est pas pour
ça que je pète un plomb que poèmes
étaient à la 80e place mon pote
[Musique]
ouais alors allé en attendant - mais
audiences radio elle monte elle monte
les audiences radio toi non et pourquoi
parce que j'ai pas d'émissions de radio
et ben voilà abattent un adoptant
l'animateur radio c'est pas là tu es
gentil
allait-il hockey et sinon le pas qui lie
les deux dents pas je crois que oui
alors temps peuvent là on en est où les
frérots de la vega non là on à jean
rochefort jean rochefort jean jouer
devant sirigu en championnat les
marabouts nanou d'un david benoit l'on
regarde devant et aux français aussi
c'est comme quoi le monde est bien fait
il est là et là cyril hanouna 100e
centièmes
on s'est pas mal et centièmes c'est pas
mal ouais ouais sur combien surba sûr
sans fil
sur 100 assez galère non mais ceci dit
en voyant les choses et il est premier
en partant de la fin tu es bien ou très
bien où tu veux c'est dommage parce que
il était pas mal étant jeune ah d'accord
mais depuis la revue les oreilles j'ai
l'air laisse coi si c'est ça c'est ça
bon ben écoute je te laisse je vais
remettre le prix aux pâquis et puis je
tombe
ok bijoux eskimos veut